against that pawn on
H5 and so the Knight dropped
back uh black G was anticipating that F3
was unavoidable he didn't want to make
any uh kingside weaknesses for example
strategically speaking it would have
probably been a poor decision to play H4
as that would have meant that the queen
could come out here and harass the
pawn likewise in case of G6 all that
does is weaken a lot of the dark squares
around Black's King which is great for
White's dark Square Bishop so that's why
we saw the retreat the voluntary Retreat
or involuntary retreat at Knight F6 and
now we see Rook D1 Queen C7
H3 making LT what does that mean in
chess when we make our lft just a little
bit of an air hole just a little we give
our King a little air so that we don't
have to suffer the indignities of a back
ranked
Checkmate so after H3 Rook
d8 B3 small little move useful with the
move B3 white is saying I'm I'm re
fortifying my Pawn on C4 again nothing
Earth shattering and Rook D7 I would
describe this as a waiting move um black
um says to White K basically you tell me
how you intend to make progress in this
position yeah and what do you think
about that how what would your plan be
here for white as yes because I love I
like White's position but how they
increase it exactly I mean the the one
nice point about H5 as we pointed out
earlier is that it's kind of encouraged
to move H3 to prevent an H4 H3 and also
to make L which makes F3 a little bit
less palatable but that doesn't mean
that it won't be played anyway right you
might play F3 anyway and try to maybe
put a bishop when you want at some point
well sometimes when you have a position
like this where you're a little bit like
the moves aren't coming easy for you
like in in terms of developing a
long-term plan one of the best things
that you can do is make moves that you
feel uh are incrementally improve your
own position so in this position I take
a look at my queen for example and I say
well my queen isn't exactly on an deal
Square how could I improve my queen I'd
probably just play a little bit a little
move like Queen F3 and let's just we're
just going to go back and forth for a
little moment we're going to say black
says okay what are you doing really I
would play another little improvement
improvement kind of move G3 King G2 huh
King G2 little little little Improvement
moves and now when I feel the stage is
properly set and I'm not saying now is
the time but when I feel I've set the
the stage properly I'm going to try to
make this move oh I like that idea
expand on the king side and why did I
need to move for this whole line of Play
to work why did I need to move my king
to G2 so that I could slide my Rook
across to the H you said you were trying
to make little moves and now you're
trying to Checkmate well little moves
lead to big things you know deceiving
yes it's yeah that that looks very
dangerous so that's something that uh
got will will start to anticipating if
he sees the uh the king move up to G2
and what will he do about it we will
find out not a question I mean he might
try to play H4 himself at some
moment so we like like maybe even maybe
even if if a queen F3 maybe even before
something like G3 now of course that
weakens that pawn quite you mean H4
immediately
Jen yeah but that's a big committing
move I know it is isn't it and and what
do we mean by that when we say switch
around and play Bishop B1 and F3 right
just stle the pawn precisely now that
you've put the pawn on a dark square and
we have this dark squared Bishop maybe
we start to eyeball what you've just
said bringing our Bishop back to E1 so
that at some future moment that pawn on
H4 becomes an ideal Target now if I were
black here after the move Queen F3 I
know it's not the move we necess oops
excuse me I don't I'll take the move H4
back for a moment it's not NE
necessarily A Move like I'm dying to
play this move or anything like this but
at certain moment I may feel as black
that I don't want to wait all day like I
I want to force the action and it's
that's going to lead some issues with
your Bishop Bishop coming to C3 H5
possibly hanging right something so
you're looking calculate that perfectly
right right you got to make sure that
you don't hang your face when you play
something like this so takes on E5 you
mean takes on D1 yes and you're probably
going to recapture with the queen so you
can play Bishop C3 yeah I want to try
playing Bishop C3 and S exactly so that
how you hang on to everything in the end
right so well one of the things I'm
really hoping for is that maybe one day
this Pawn on A5
becomes a source of counterplay so for
instance if you move your queen to F5
here yes exactly and I take on F6 that's
right now if Queen takes F6 uh the pawn
on H5 hangs but you got this little
sneaky idea right that was playing Rook
to E5 although even that I don't know if
that's going to be adequate because uh I
have the queen G4 here right and uh so
this is a long- winded variation but at
the end of the day white may just end up
a pawn to the good now and of course you
you could alternatively take on F6 with
the pawn earlier in the variation but
that would leave you with a totally
busted Pawn structure not
what godsky want in all the solid player
does not like that in the least right so
um we uh we've actually got a
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley with a few
thoughts on this game as well all
right well Jen it seems like this game
is going in super slow motion definitely
not Brooklyn style it's the kind of game
you wonder about is Carlson really ready
to expend a lot of energy at the
beginning of the tournament and we've
seen him do this start off really slowly
even though he's the number one player
in the world and only later pick up the
pace he's unlike Gary casparo for
example in this way and that Gary wanted
to win every single game start off
strong and win by plus six clearly this
is a very short tournament and he's
going to have to think about winning
early especially since he's playing the
lowest rated player in the tournament
and yet he still seems extremely calm
extremely relaxed and not looking to
play any big moves any moves like F3 E4
like we saw could have happened earlier
now why is that one reason might be that
kamsky has been such a problem for him
even when he plays these super sharp
positions and we have a game from 2012
in tata steel that they played that I
like to show you a dramatic sequence
that took place as you see here Carlson
had the white pieces it was a real Lopez
really open kind of position and ksky
had to face this move Knight to D2
attacking his pawn and he played the
move F5 opening up his King defending
the pawn but definitely opening up this
diagonal and after the move F3 Carlson
applying the pressure to the pawn the
move E3 was played attacking this Knight
but of course this pin is preventing any
danger for to that Knight as yet and the
response a barn burner C4 attacking the
Knight on D5 and you would have maybe
expected this capture uh-uh Knight to F4
of all moves allowing C takes B5 check
to the king and attacking the bishop as
well the king moved into the corner not
even Bishop D5 King in the corner
allowing this capture to happen because
if it had been the next move then the
move Queen to G5 would have threatened
Maiden one and also the Knight on D2 so
crazy line now so after King to
h8 after the king move he decided not to
capture the bishop instead he played
Knight to C fored Carlson and now the
move E2 the pawn rushing down the board
remember his Bishop is hanging on this
Square temporarily down a pawn is black
and after Queen D2 the move Queen to G5
threatening check Maiden one move
forcing virtually Rook takes E2 Knight
takes E2 check and then Queen takes and
now Bishop takes on B5 black emerged up
an exchange for a pawn in this position
and milked tried to milk the position
for quite a while eventually they ended
up somewhere in in this kind of
position Carlson had to fight
tremendously but he was able to deal
with be down in exchange and make this
Pawn so much trouble that kamsky had to
accept a draw but it just goes to show
that this particular opponent gakamsky
has not been an easy one for Carlson and
so he's decided you know what I'm not
going to get too crazy against this guy
let me see if I can squeeze him and win
the game with a little less headache and
heart palpitations guys yeah thank you
that was a sharp sequence of moves what
a graen that was that's right and that
was a tournament that we keep coming
back to in our commentary the uh the
Tata steel tournament right um which uh
Caron won yes and as uh Maurice was
mentioning this is a when you think in
terms of the elite tournaments this is
kind of the kickoff event the premier
event occurs every January to start the
chess season to start the new year and
that tournament regularly features world
champions and Challengers and the best
of the best and the highlight of our our
own hikaro nakam moris career was
winning that Championship right in 2011
that was a great breakthrough for hikaro
I was very very proud and delighted with
the success now we're going to actually
uh go to a quick break but I want to
remind everyone uh our our hashtag syn
cup join the likes of uh super
Grandmaster Nigo short and chime in with
your own comments and questions and also
you can use the email questions at St
Louis chess club.org and we will be back
with uh much more from the singfield cop
here in St Louis all righty
then okay so that did not
happen and instead uh Magnus played C
takes
D5 F5 anyway the San zook attacking the
queen forcing the queen wish the uh the
tactic of grand Masters right they see
the works in the pins with his wish it
it comes up at every every level of of
Chess absolutely uh Queen F3 and now
this was a huge decision how to
recapture this Pawn on on D5 clearly uh
got would not want to leave his F5 Pawn
on Prix after e takes D5 he didn't do
that but I was a bit surprised he didn't
recapture with the Rook I thought he
would play Rook takes D5 in order to
keep the C5 clo cfile closed that didn't
occur that does look rather powerful
okay so instead he he ended up taking
with the
seon which really uh gave white an open
invitation to try to double his Rooks on
the C file so that rook's gone from C2
to C1 back to C2 so if we didn't know
this was the number one player in
history you might think he was just was
shuffling around he was shuffling around
but of course the situation has changed
quite a bit and with this move Rook D7 I
really should give a comment to that
from him with this shift Rook
D7 to G7 what God is making very clear
is he's planning to really rock him
sakam on the king side he's playing all
out for a kingside attack and he's
burned his play Rook cuz he wanted to
play he wanted to leave that Rook open
for the attack exactly so this is
incredible I mean this guy is not saying
oh I'm going to play Black against car
play solid try to draw no he's really
going for here and absolutely got to
love it so now with Rook C1 as played so
what with these Rooks doubled on the SE
file what white is angling for is an
opportunity to uh play Rook C8 one day
and hopefully there'll be a queen and a
king on on the back Rank and white would
win material the problem is I mean we
don't really uh we don't really want to
give up uh two Rooks for a queen in this
position do we I'm not sure we do but
let's just imagine for the Rocks yeah
let's just imagine that g goes Allin as
the poker world would say Allin how
about this move G5 G4 you're pretty much
obligated to capture that pawn I don't
yeah I better take it you better take it
and now let's imagine Rook takes G5 now
this may look barbaric but if black
could play Queen G5 and you know bring
everything to the G file this G2 Pawn
could be sensitive or he might even play
for Knight E4 to uh G5 and H4 H3 this is
really heating up um shall we continue
the line with Rook C s for a moment yeah
let's try R C7 sure right and now black
to play how can he strengthen his
attack shall we just go for it let's
well you've got a a couple of ways to go
for it so you're just going to try to
double I mean I was thinking your your
idea night G5 is also also a we
considering immediately but okay well
let's just see so Knight G5 attacks the
queen forces White's Queen to step
backwards lead leaving this Pawn on G2
exposed for a moment so moves like H3
may may miss the mark though and same
with Knight H3 doesn't really lead to
much does it well let's just check it
out yeah you because you want to you
want to try maybe just playing the the
kamakazi queen G5 afterwards right I
don't think that's going to work if you
play if you play King F1 maybe we can
just play Queen G5 okay well this of
course you want to take my Pawn on G2 as
well as uh well just breakthrough on the
G5 but here I'm thinking Queen F3
defends the pawn and makes the it kind
of embarrasses the night a little bit
here I think black has gone too far
right right we need a more graceful way
to infiltrate then take away that one
square which we also need for a knight
exactly so maybe we'll keep the knight
in the center of the board for a moment
and let's go back to this move King h8
because I'm curious what the outcome of
of a A variation this like this might be
now let's double double up with the
Rooks both players going after one
another's
Kings very exciting uh this would be a
very exciting way to to continue yeah
what what a kick off start cup running
Checkmate in one like that that's a good
Checkmate so black comes back with his
Knight protects the Checkmate and
keeps Rook G2 or how's this as a l as a
variation Knight comes back to G5
protects the check made it makes Rook
takes G2 kind of discover checks
possible not sure let's go back that
would be funny than then if you play
King F1 let's just just for fun let's
show that
line uh after Knight G5 Knight G5 if you
play if you if you move your king here
let's let's do that for fun oh King F1
oh I see Knight A3 Rook H7 you don't
take the you
go ja but instead maybe you can do our
our padn in between move and play Queen
takes C7 in this
position uh how does that go so what
instead of King F1 oh no no no after
King F1 Queen P C7 here and every
everything's hanging in the this s Sweet
have a having a little party well this
is what mauce says the beautiful thing
and the easy thing for us is we get to
analyze and when we blow it which we do
all the time we get to take our moves
back the players don't get it that's why
this is such an intense moment because
one mistake in this type of position and
it's uh the difference between a win and
a loss not all chest positions are like
that some you build up uh advantages
incrementally but here this is a mess
and it's it's going to some high stakes
chess going on right now without
question we got to play G4 in this
position I don't think so I think what G
will will likely want to do is maybe
just prepare that move uh G5 G4 with
something a little bit more wholesome
how could he do that what would be a
good building move that uh uh doesn't
lose any of for wholesome moves in this
position yes Maurice wants to rip white
the shreds right well you know he's from
Brooklyn that's what they do in Brooklyn
the same thing different words for the
same thing right what they say they're
just going all out here um I'm I'm
looking at a wild line let me just let
me just throw some some ideas on the
board so I can just share taking with a
pawn instead of the rock taking with the
pawn instead of The Rook they're both
tempting I mean it's it's hard to decide
right so that in case of a move like
Queen I'm just I'm just throwing all
bridges here wide open um probably I'm
going to miss my mark this is the type
of thing that white is looking for
however we recapture the queen whether
with the king or with the queen there's
this uh Rook C8 to completely diffuse
the attack and white would be winning in
this ending and uh Magnus Carlson's
actually gotten up from the board and
looks rather relaxed but uh does that
Bly uh worries about his position what
do you think Maurice
well I have to say first of all that I'm
very happy the way this game is gone
because it's super exciting now we would
not have expected it and kamsky has gone
all the way maybe burning a few Bridges
just to get here but it's certainly the
kind of position we want to see happen
in this game however it may not be going
anywhere because of the
One Plus in White's position and that's
the SE file I mean these Rooks on the C
file shut things down so rapidly and you
can look at White's position and tell
that white king side okay the pawns are
coming down but it's just not that weak
and black doesn't have the Plus in
pieces that he needs in order to make
this King have any real worries of
course when you see pawns riging down on
your king position you start thinking
that maybe there might be a problem but
in this case the move G4 looks just
about like the thing you should do but
after takes you pointed out the line
Rook takes I've been looking at some
lines with the computer Rook C7 looks
very strong Pawn T seems to be the best
way to go but exactly how do you crack
this nut of the King's Castle position
it's just not so obvious what the point
should be that you should hit either
moves like H3 or G3 they it just doesn't
Define itself like very clearly and
white is always ready to drop this Rook
down either on C7 or on C8 as you
mentioned yes in case of something like
Rook to f8 there's always a sacrifice so
I think this is why Carlson is really
calm in this position in some ways I
feel like he doesn't deserve it because
the way he's played this game so far has
been so absolutely Ted Rook C2 Rook back
to C1 it's just like what are you doing
but kamsky feeling himself feeling maybe
he has an opportunity may have gotten
into a situation where it might still be
balanced but certainly no fear in
White's heart that this position will
somehow lead to Checkmate on black side
the organization just does not look so
great of the black pieces back to you
guys thank you Maurice and uh yeah it's
fun looking at all these different
possibilities for black but truth is God
has got to pick one and he's got to pick
it pretty soon and it looks like he has
made a move he does have a a Time
deficit in this game against Carlon and
the decisions the high ahead of him are
going to be crucial to say the least
exactly so he's got eight minutes to
Carlson's 30 wow so big big difference
there and of course we do have the 30
second increment but wow in a position
this wild you're need more than that to
figure out all the ramifications exactly
and critical decisions in over these
course of the next two three moves will
definitely Define the outcome of the
game and whether or not Black's
initiative on the king side is really
Justified or not remember a comment from
a dear friend colleague chess Legend in
American chess circles Walter Shan Brown
six-time US champion sometime the
comment he said is sometimes you need to
give your opponent a little rope to hang
himself and I'm not sure that uh Gada
hasn't taken the rope
and hung himself well he did not play G4
he played Knight back to F6 first
perhaps repairing to play
G4 that move I didn't expect no we did
not expect that move at all because the
Knight did look quite powerful on e4
Square already and especially with the
ideas of playing G4 and perhaps moving
the night back to G5 and in certain
variations so what's up with this move
what is he trying to do next is he going
to is he going to play the G4 anyway and
try to perhaps even take with a knight
well we have seen remember the lines we
looked at where there was a doubled Rook
on the SE file well we saw one
variation where the Knight on F6 was
important to stop white from playing
Rook H7 Checkmate let me um um play the
the trumpeteer for uh G in this position
so so one of the reasons why the Knight
is actually very well placed on the
Square H6 is you're not playing Queen H5
at any time let me go back one move and
suggest that this move G5 G4 is very
powerful in case the Rooks were doubled
on the G file so imagine I had played
King here and we're just going to make a
move for white not a good move and Rook
here with the now with the idea of
playing G4 well one of the things that
white could do to interfere with that
plan is to play Queen H5 check to
Black's King so with the move Knight F6
what G is saying is listen I'm going to
prepare doubling on the oops I'm going
to prepare doubling on the G file I will
play the move Knight
F6 with the idea I'm going to move my
king I'm going to move my Rook I'm going
to then play G4 and by the way what are
you doing for a move what is actually
White's great idea he does have
wonderful Rooks on the sea file but as
we see the business squares C7 and C8
are adequately protected and this is a
perfect position for Rook so in Lesnar's
a specific concrete position Carlson's
not going to seriously consider Rook C8
with the idea of trying to get the queen
for the two Rooks this would just be a
very nice position with the Rooks the
position is too closed I think to
benefit the Queen the queen wants some
open lines to get some tricky checks
this on the other hand the uh the back
rank that that Rook is eyeing just looks
fabulous and uh this position will be
too strong for black and a case in point
is because the queen is really being
arrested that Knight on F6 is blocking
the queen from getting truly active
let's see sometimes a queen can be
plenty for two Rooks but usually in more
open positions than this is a bit too
closed right so that being said uh
what's Carlson going to do and Y he had
had to pick a side who would you take
here white or black I like black you
would take black here of course knowing
the time situation you'd probably take
white out the time situation I just Unos
just un position if if time if the clock
was not a factor I do like uh uh Black's
position after Knight F6 what was
magnus's move did he really retreat with
his Queen yes it says that he's played
Queen to D1 so lots of back and forth
here now is he trying to set up some
kind aline's gun um we call that the
when the queen goes behind the two Rooks
and actually infiltrate with the major
piece cuz that's what white wants to do
it's almost has that kind of King's
Indian look to the position where
White's position would be fabulous if
you gave us the Moves uh you know Rook
C3 Rook C2 Queen C1 Rook C8 if I could
play all those moves at once your
weaknesses would show right no attack
yet and I'm trading everything off I'm
going to be doing great okay well let's
uh let let me play uh the advocate for
godess position you had asked me uh
whose position I would prefer to play uh
with the
queen let's say with the queen now
having one of the reasons I was kind of
reluctant to play the move G5 G4 is I
was worried that I might push your queen
to a better Square on F4 right now that
you have voluntarily retreated the queen
to D oh pardon me yeah got to get KN F6
Queen to D1 the move G5 G4 becomes very
attractive once more has he played it I
believe he has so there goes g and so
what is G's point that after you trade
let's say takes takes takes okay and now
I know there's a lot of there's been a
lot of uh two and frowing but the idea
of Rook f8 Knight E4 coming back
attacking the pawn on F2 and also with
the move H4 H3 the beautiful part about
this move let me just make a move for
white for a moment so I can just show it
after I play the move H3 be honest
what's your knee-jerk
reaction you will play G3 would you not
uh G3 I mean I'm I'm making some
horrendous holes on F3 exactly you're
coming to get me with Knight H7 remember
we looked at that earlier right we
didn't like it so much earlier Knight H7
but now it's starting to be very
attrative hot that we have the G5 Square
so in a Blitz game if you saw the move
H3 well you wouldn't want to open up
your king
clear and you may think well I don't
want black to capture on G2 either so if
you you do a knee-jerk reaction with a
move G3 Knight E4 is obviously even more
graceful way to go about this uh looking
to uh put the Knight on F3 in that a
strategic
domination that white will not
allow so
got um putting threats on magnus's
position and after G
G4 Magnus has played
F3 F3
wow oh wow you mean he hasn't taken
first he didn't he just played F3 here
that's what it looks like on my monitor
okay because H4 is hanging so I guess
he's I guess he feels that G2 is
defended laterally and he's if if uh
something takes on F3 or H3 he's just
going to play Bishop takes H4 and try to
hold a lot of the pieces at Bay both
you're kind of when you take on H4
you're kind of holding the Knight and
the queen simultaneously because the
knight's in a PIN to the queen yeah so
this is is very so let's see what we
defensive concept I mean one that not
not that it's it's bad but it's just
like not something that would occur to
most people to allow all these juicy
captures for black right right so in
other words black has been very
successful in ripping open White's King
but
simultaneously Black's King is also
exposed after a line This is mag also no
revert to our work8 idea though like
that's another issue because yeah the
Knight ahuh so I would have had the
concepts here so maybe I would have had
to do it in this position I would have
to have played Rook takes G2 so what
you're what Jen has correctly stated
is that this Knight is an a pin by the
bishop to the queen and if we capture
with the pawn uh Jen points out well
Rook C8 and lots of moves have been
played I see the players we've got to
catch up with the players looks too good
so yeah uh this actually this concept
this defensive concept of F3 seems uh
like a really creative defensive concept
because I I don't think he can go for
that line so what did what it got to do
instead after F3 he did did take on
H3 wow he take on H and then H4 did
occur and now probably he did go for
your move Rook takes G2 didn't he what
did he do well that's the question uh
who is to play Bishop takes H4 has been
played and from magnus's point of view I
think Magnus is very happy that his
Bishop that had been sitting on E1
passively is now in the game um on
pinning the knight uh to the queen on d8
so Magnus may be dodging a bit of a
bullet here in the last two moves or so
look at that the the Improvement of that
Bishop earlier on B4 just durmont not
really doing anything it's uh somehow
now just a an incredibly powerful piece
holding down two of blacks men on its
own exactly wow so the question is uh
what do goty to do here if he plays the
move you mentioned Rook takes G2 check
right let's see how that goes so now
that that stop the idea of Rook
C8 but even here it just looks like uh
Black's pieces are so tied down and we
have a a number of options here we could
try something just like ignore the pawn
on G2 for the moment to play something
like Queen
C2 try to infiltrate on C7 fair enough
one of the funny things and I I remember
when I was a class player I it really
made a powerful impression on me it was
like an almost an epiphany the idea that
this Pawn on G2 could act as a shield
for Whit's King in other words white is
in no hurry as you've just demonstrated
too stronger though that's got to be
stronger Rook C2 speaking of I do like
your queen C2 actually oh you don't like
Rook C2 here no I I think Rook C2 is a
fine move let's say I would play King
here if you were to capture on on G2
with your Rook well I'd probably want to
trade Rooks true but once you play King
F7 I could switch back and go for that
kind of more alakin gun type spot where
I play Queen C1 and get the The Rook
behind the The Rook in front of the
queen ready to go Rook
C7 I'm not sure how this is all going to
you have rookie you just have Rook E7 or
something I don't know no Ju Just how
it's going to pan out you have to be
careful if you don't take this Pawn on
G2 one day it might bite you in the butt
and so Rook h8 yeah that's true so we
have to be pretty accurate here yeah
okay but I did like your queen C2 very
much and I thought that that was a very
uh good move and after Queen C2 let's
say King F7 and Maurice this is a tough
position uh please share your
insights oh yeah like I know I mean this
position is crazy and it has gone hog
while even analyzing it with a computer
the position is nuts but it's amazing to
see how kamsky has decided to go for it
and how cool Magnus Carlson is under
pressure come on a lot of us would be
sweating seeing those pawns come down
opening up the king the way he has to
move F3 but this kid is so smooth so
cool like is anything bothering him at
all like it's just a stroll in the park
and everyday chess position with your
king under assault from pawns and Rooks
and potential but I think he's
definitely looking for moves here that
could be tricky or could somehow get him
out of this situation and I've looked at
this position like I said I got to look
at the moves when it gets this chaotic
you want to look at some of the moves
with the computer to see what it thinks
and it has this idea this interesting
maneuver of playing this queen over to
E1 and this idea is quite intriguing
what he's trying to do is reinforce the
G3 Square to eventually be able to push
on G3 or also to maybe sneak in the
queen after an exchange on F6 so that
the Rook can come in on this side so
this very delicate move Queen E1 also
guards the pawn on A5 it just shows the
amazing power of the queen to stretch in
two different directions and then begin
to pressure either side of the board so
Queen E1 interesting move again these
moves that the guys are playing they're
showing their High level this is 2700
2800 chess incredible moves we just
really couldn't even guess at some of
these moves and ideas and it just goes
to show that we are indeed in what is
known as a super tournament here at the
singfield cup back to you guys that's
right what a way to start the singfield
cup what a k a game that looks like it's
kind of dry and then so many Ked ideas
beautiful right shows how rich the game
is now let's take a quick look at our
other game we haven't seen it for a
while Nakamura on on when we had left
that game uh hikaro was nursing the
advantage of what we call the two
Bishops we all liked hikaru's position
uh when we left it we'll go back back
back we were in this position and this
is where I had come up with the normal
human move Queen D3 attacking the Knight
on F5 Maurice pointed out that the
computer really liked the move Knight A5
and it led to a series of Trades that
was advantageous for white fabulous move
Knight A5 I love it um Hikaru played C3
which is actually a pretty interesting
move in the sense that you uh Jen you
were you really wanted to stop this
knight from jumping into D4 for obvious
reasons the Knight is powerful on this
Square D4 so Hikaru played the move C3
but that gave that Tempo gave black the
move that he needed to kind of
consolidate his position after trades H6
this was a key move he attacked the
bishop this bishop is defending this
Square d8 so with this move leavon could
push away the bishop so his Rooks could
enter The Fray Queen D3 G6 Bishop D2
Rook d8 the move that black has been
angling for for a long time Queen E2
step back and now Knight
F4 okay attacking White's Queen it does
look like Leana solving more problems
than what Hikaru had created so maybe
White's Advantage seems to have slipped
here and the Very fact that he was
forced to give up his Bishop Advantage
tells me that
uh has actually uh done well to take a
lot of the tension out of the position
and see3 also helped neutralize Black's
kind of natural Pawn structure
disadvantage in the Roy Lopez usually
black starts off with a worst structure
in the Roy because he makes all these
committal pawn moves and we saw that in
some of the variations that we looked at
where we thought hiar was better but
when he plays C3 and there's a trade we
we've had a much more symmetrical
situation exactly we we thought that the
pawns on C5 and B4 were potential
targets and thanks to White after the
move C3 black was able to dissolve one
of his potential targets and it looks
like leavon has has solved what seemed
to be a serious problem also this move
Bishop D5 this is a fabulous uh
neutralizing move this bishop on B3 the
Spanish torture Bishop uh with the move
Bishop D5 uh the bishop on B3 has been
neutralized have more moves been played
Knight D2 was played and do we have any
moves since Knight D2 no well this is a
funny turnaround because we we predicted
that this was going to be the slash and
burn game of the round right whereas it
seems that uh Lana making some nice
neutralizing moves and more trades are
coming exactly whereas the other game
which we thought was going to be a
little bit High a up yes you never know
how it's going to go and Maurice you
have some thoughts to
share indeed there's a great line to
take a look at in the game with with
Carlson versus kamsky this is a
fascinating variation he in fact did
Carlson play the move Queen to E1 we've
seen a lot of strange moves from the
world number one player I guess that's
why he is the world number one player
and his move Queen D1 by the way earlier
in the game which you thought was a
surprise Yes actually turned out to be
the computer's First Choice now it
didn't think his F3 was the best move so
just goes to show that even the the
Silicon monster doesn't necessarily
agree with the world number one all the
time but it also thought quy1 was great
and and Carlson has indeed play play
that move and it seems as if he's really
triangulating on Black's position it
looks as though he's under attack but in
fact Black's King is shaky in of itself
and so the simpler lines go if you were
to take on G2 right now for black black
would face this move Rook to C7 check
and after Rook to E7 blocking that check
now Bishop takes Knight hitting
everything in the position this bishop
has to go and then after Queen to H4
check King drops back and now the nice
move Rook takes Pawn on B7 when you
cannot capture back on B7 because there
would go the queen so this position
would clearly be winning and after Rook
takes B7 it's not white who's under
attack but in fact black who's under
pressure now another line we could look
at there if we were to go back to this
position instead of taking on G2 with
the pawn you could play Rook takes on G2
actually I have to do this manually here
let me just get to that position
here so Bishop takes H4 King to F7 Queen
to E1 and now if you play Rook takes G2
this is the big advantage of moving the
queen over takes takes because it can go
to G3 and suddenly you realize that Rook
C7 check is possible and the queen these
pieces are closing in much better into
the position for white than it is for
black Black's attacking idea seem to
Simply have evaporated and it's white
for choice so Carlson showing why this
this young Phenom has broken the 2850
2860 2870 barrier because he's playing
chess From Another World back to you
guys thank you Maurice and by the way
the variations that you were just uh
showing us is the case in point where
it's the black Pawn on G2 that's the
disadvantage in the position for black
because of those moves like Queen
G3 and in fact um uh G has uh captured
with the pawn and the variation uh just
to repeat what Marie showed was that
after Rook C7 check the most natural
move in the position give a check in
case the Rook blocks the check Bishop
takes
F6 Now The Rook on C7 can't be captured
because the bishop attacks the queen in
that case so the bishop has to be
captured Queen H4 check the king drops
back and this was a key moment this is
an easy move to miss I must confess Rook
takes B7 Rook takes B7 very cool that is
a
very nasty nasty move cuz it's a
combination of a pen and uh just a just
just a very visual but not a typical way
to take advantage of a pen right exactly
it's like these two pins first you have
the absolute pin against the king and
then you have the relative pin against
the queen and white wins a pawn for
example we're just going to make a move
for black not necessarily a good move
but just to to
demonstrate the possibility of white
just transposing instantly into a king
and Pawn in game a pawn to the good that
pawn on G2 and now we take our Shield we
don't need it anymore now we and thanks
to this Pawn on the queen side black
would end up having to resign so losing
that B7 Pawn could be the pivotal moment
in the game that decides the game for
csky and we've and it looks like uh it
looks like we've got a lot of moves on
uh Nakamura aonan oh really I should
switch let me switch the board game we
we've seen a whole bunch of Trades and I
wonder if that's a that's over soon
what's going on over there let me bring
up I am sorry let me bring
up where is my oh lot wow whoa wait a
second what has just happened I thought
I thought we were going to see a bunch
of Trades that might lead to a drawish
position but that position after KN D7
what's going on it looks like they're
work on F eight is well when we left the
game we left it at this point Nakamura
hikaro just dropped back with his Knight
Bishop takes Knight takes Queen takes
leavon capturing that pawn on A4 Knight
captures C5 restoring material equality
and look at this Knight D7 a winner oh
and look at nakamura's face is that a
happy is that a happy face I don't think
so oh no I think so he's looking good
he's looking very good knight D7 why
Knight what is that face why is this
move such a leing back on his chair why
is this so powerful so in the first
place we're threatening to capture a
rook but that Rook cannot move from the
f8 square if it goes to E8 there's this
devastating Knight Fork Knight checks
attacks the king and attacks The Rook
that would win on the spot but the Rook
has nowhere else to go and I think it's
a winning move so just Knight takes f8
is coming and uh White is just up in
exchange I mean black can't even get a
pawn for this now where did leavon go
wrong that the sequence just uh you know
catapulted out of control I mean it
seemed like it was a relatively simple
sequence uh Maurice what happened here
this is simply astonishing that the
world number two player would blunder at
this kind of level in a position where
he was perfectly fine and we see this
happen so often you're in trouble for a
little bit you're struggling you're
trying to equalize and then when you
equalize you start to think okay I have
no problems here everything is fine and
then you relax and when you relax that's
when you have the brain freeze and you
blunder and it was a very specific
moment in this game when this happened
we saw the exchanges is with Bishop
takes on D5 uh let me just get back to
this position for us when he was so
confident here that this was nothing was
going to happen to him just go back one
moment so In This Moment he played
Bishop to D5 and then he just decided oh
look at this easy trades uh let me now
get rid of this
Pawn sorry let me push that back one
second back one
move let me get rid of that pawn and now
Knight takes on C5 and it looked like
you know no big deal let's just uh trade
Queens in fact he had a much simpler
move simply Queen to C6 was easy Queen
C6 hitting the Knight and also this Pawn
on C3 so if Knight takes Pawn simply
Queen takes he cover the D7 Square there
will be no issues whatsoever Queen to C6
was a very simple comfortable way to
equalize the position and he was in fact
right he was still equal the move that
he played however Queen B7 Queen to B5
uh has resulted
has resulted in this position sorry
again let me just get back to this queen
to B after Knight takes on C5 Queen to
B5 and then this is just dumb stuff
Queen takes Pawn takes and Knight D7 and
you're losing an exchange it's just one
move you're just losing in exchange so a
horrible horrible blunder on aonian part
he's going to be kicking himself he only
has six games to play to lose this game
in this style has got to be totally
embarrassing ing he's going to die now
there's no question about it Nakamura is
going to figure out how to use this
exchange and Hammer him into the ground
so this is going to be a win for
Nakamura barring some other mysterious
mistakes it should just be an easy fluid
win for Nakamura so an stunning start to
the sinkfield cup here on this very
first round back to you guys yeah I mean
I don't know what to say about this
blunder what can you say about it how
could he miss it do you think he just uh
just uh hallucinated he thought the
other Rook was on f8 perhaps the other
Rook was on d8 Rook on A8 if the Rook on
if it was The Rook on A8 it wouldn't be
an issue right true I think uh Marissa
simply nailed it uh at a certain moment
after the move Queen takes A4 was played
Knight takes C5 I'm absolutely certain
that leavon simply relaxed and said all
my problems are over and they are with
the correct move Queen C6 I'm sure he
would have made a very comfortable draw
oh yeah and that was end of it and then
he said well why do I have to play Queen
C6 isn't Queen B5 even more comfortable
and because he was relaxed he just he
had a blind uh a blackout he simply
forgot about Knight D7 I'm sure he had
seen it in earlier variations that he
had analyzed and then suddenly he got to
the board and this moment the momentary
reflex and that's going to cost him the
game now why does Nakamura look so upset
he's the one who's in the uh driver SE
now he's ready to crush but yet he looks
almost angry it's funny how you you know
his emotions are are interesting that
way feeling a little bit of sympathy for
his opponent I don't think so I don't
think so nakara um if only that black
king was on G7 then there would be no
problem he could play Rook E8 so after
uh Knight D7 I believe Rook A8 what has
been played after Knight D7 what did uh
um he play um yeah it looks like we got
a bunch of moves in over there Knight C5
Queen B5 Queen B5 ab5 Knight D7 Rook
takes D7 Rook takes D7 then Rook A8 I
see so that's how it went Knight D7 Rook
takes D7 Rook takes D7 Rook A8 so both
players are fully aware of course that
uh a horrible horrible mistake has been
has taken place that black is simply uh
lost and now uh hikaro is just searching
for the best way of reeling home the the
full Point St Louis fans are cheering
andan fans
are
happy absolute CH genius momentary
weakness and that's the difference
between humans and computers right I
mean this uh this guy who can uh
calculate variations that Astound us all
has just one second melt toown but that
can cost him the game to error is human
to error is human and after uh but okay
Jen uh here a question for you I mean
you're let let's say you had this
position and you know you just know
you've got the technical victory in hand
would you go for G4 here with the idea
that you're going to force this Knight
to move right and then play Rook down
with the idea of Rook takes F7 and we
know that's a kind of a devastating that
looks I mean that look very tempting I
mean you want to be be sure to calculate
it carefully though because there's
probably uh you know ways to win that
you don't even need to calculate right
that's the point you're taking a little
risk with this line but do you take the
risk because it looks so uh promising uh
for example well I mean you can take and
play Knight Knight D5 but then there's
also the H4 at the end so right that's
the scorpion sting right there that's
the move that pushes the Knight away
from the defense of the F7 pawn and
that's a winner Maurice what's your
thoughts well this position certainly
looks like it's winning for Nakamura and
you're pointing out y it's really a
question of technique right now how do
you do it do you play a move G4 first
you saw nakamura's attitude I think he's
probably thinking dude you should resign
and he's sitting there you know with all
those looks on his face cuz I'm of an
exchange do you really think I'm going
to let you off the hook and so he's
focused now Leon in his heart is just
devastated like a punch in the gut he's
sitting there thinking I got cameras on
me this is a big tournament and I just
made a child's blunder incredibly when I
was just getting out of all the dangers
so he's got to just settle himself
breathe deeply and deal with the fact
that all right I'm going to lose this
game but there's still five games to go
but that's so hard to do when you've
just blundered so horribly with the
lights on you in a way that's just not
him at all we know this guy's a Super
Genius so he's going to have to explain
to us why he did what he did now in the
other game there's some real exciting
developments going on because it looks
as though kamsky is about to get
triangulated pretty awfully in his game
we saw from this position a few moves
got played uh the the move we expected
was Bishop takes F6 after Rook C7 check
Rook to E7 he did Play Bishop takes F6
and after King takes instead of playing
this queen H4 check he decided to get
even meaner he played the move Rook to
C8 attacking the queen in this position
and after Queen to D6 uh happened he
played Queen to H4 check or at least I
think we're waiting for him to play
Queen to H4 check yes he did play this
move Queen to H4 with check and the King
had to drop back to F7 and now there's a
nasty maneuver Queen to H5 check forcing
this Rook to block and then Queen to h8
and just look at that black king it is
being circled by the Wolves he's not
going to last long in this position
pretty horrible situation for kamsky it
looked like he was trying to attack at
first and now it seems that the attacker
is the one who is being hunted so two
what looks like big wins to start off
the singfield cup things are not over
yet but it seems to be trending that way
back to you Jen and yes that's right at
this level of Chess you see a lot of
draws but it looks today we might have
two decisive ones in that uh final
position Maurice was showing there were
two mate and one threats on the board
right and just total infiltration there
by Carlson which is so interesting
because he made all these backward moves
right queen1 Rook C1 Rook C2 and then
Checkmate right that's nice huge turns
in the in these two games uh the first
we've seen by ronian by the way yeah
let's that ksky board because it's a
Hikaru did play King F2 he didn't go for
all out he didn't burn any Bridges with
the move G4 so we'll close that we'll
move over to the Magnus Carlson game and
again I just want to say that it it it
really is a remarkable feat of how this
Pawn on G2 a black pawn ends up really
protecting White's King yeah if only you
could move that Queen and that Rook away
The Rook from C1 and the queen from H4
and play Queen H2 check right and then
uh then make something happen with that
pawn and finally remove the shield but
of course uh Magnus instead has Total
Control in this position right this was
the position where there was that Rook
takes B7 variation that was very very
tempting I'm not 100% sure that Magnus
saw that but what Magnus did see and
that's very very powerful as well is
that after Rook C8 Queen D6 Queen H4
check he Magnus is on the attack now and
um it it
appears it has the whole uh csk's whole
attack has failed
and it turns out that G's King is far
more vulnerable than White's King well
that's what happens sometimes you make
these moves to H5 G5 you think you're
attacking but then you end up just
weakening yourself more precisely right
especially against uh such a formidable
opponent as uh Magnus Carlson the number
one in the world and King F7 is on the
board and now we're waiting for for
magnus's move and we're anticipating
Queen God does look a little dejected
here as you can see he's kind of P in
his face into his hands here right so we
are anticipating uh the the move that
Maurice showed that after Queen H5 to
check to the king in case of Rook G6
Maurice pointed out this move Queen
h8
threatening Queen f8 Checkmate do we
have against Rook f8 as well as Rook f8
Checkmate and it's Black's King that is
in deep trouble
suddenly and
Magnus um let's just see how would you
kill kill uh Black's position after say
Rook G6 to
G7 I don't see it instantly myself so
that's why I'm asking you Jen right so
maybe we could play um Rook f8 check and
then after team G6 only move I want to
get I want to get my other Rook into the
game so I'm going to play Rook
C2 Rook C2
how you defend that I mean it looks and
that's actually a mate threat itself
right wow you're absolutely right Rook
Queen G3 block block it for one moves
but I just but as soon as that Rook
captures that pawn with
check uh Black's toast it's that simple
yeah I mean so you have to play
something like block the queen or
something like well as you oh that just
loses yeah I mean you they block the
queen on h8 with Rook H7 or something
but back for a second or F7 so what you
were saying it's it's not going to live
long no to block like this perhaps ah
it's just but it's just over there's so
many winning moves there right you've
got Rook F6 Rook takes D2 and yeah yeah
this is
just this is a just mating mating right
H5 Queen G5 M simply mating that's all
it
takes wow what a turn around we do have
Queen H5 Rook G6 on the board and now
Magnus um ready to play uh the the the
killer blow just blocking off all all
defense here with Queen to h8 so this is
the position they have on the board
Magnus to play he's got the devastating
money move queen h8 with the twin
threats of Rook f8 Checkmate as well as
Queen f8 Checkmate we anticipate that uh
Gata will be forced to play Rook G7 in
order to give his King room but Jen has
pointed out the winning
gem no little bit of a fun
there Rook C2 and this looks like a a
good time to stop the clocks and give it
a rest Rook C2 wow so again and I I
remember very very vividly the first
time I was a class player you know
earning my spurs coming up through the
ranks when my opponent used my own
forces against me like that the pawn on
G2 what I thought was a devastating Pawn
turned out to be the shield that White's
King needed and as we see it here and it
seems like we might have had a different
move on the board though I see that
Magnus has made a move I don't think it
was Queen H maybe it wasn't Queen h8
though all right what has what did he
play all right we go back maybe he saw a
different way to finish this again
it wouldn't surprise me if he has uh a
variety of moves that might win but that
move Queen HH sure was a convincing one
yeah it it it certainly did look PR
thing what has he played instead let's
see I think we're going to find out just
momentarily okay so after Queen H5 Rook
G6 he played the move
F4
F3
wow
um okay uh that move I find to first of
all to be surprising and confusing
frankly um I think he's just trying to
play Rook C2 Rook takes G2 without
allowing uh que G3 or something yeah
because I think he just sees this Rook
is pinned on uh on on on D6 and doesn't
see a way for Cy to defend that must be
the reason right I have a I have a
slight suspicion that Magnus simply
failed to be aware of just how I'm sure
he saw the move Queen h8 but maybe he
just didn't realize its it its great
power and strength of these two
checkmating threats and I think he must
have seen a mirage that convinced him
that F4 was a better move but this is
just this has just got to be good too I
mean Black's totally tied down right he
can't like he can't escape with
something like King D7 cuz then you have
Queen AJ check anyway true just mating
in two so I mean what's what's black
going to do in the mean time well let's
ask Maurice he has play a move
Maurice well guys this is some fun stuff
for those of us who like to see Kings
get ripped apart and the move F4 was not
the most accurate move in the position
actually Queen ha8 was definitely the
right move to play but Black's position
is so bad the king so exposed look at
this king with the queen and Rook
circling that white could actually
afford the luxury of playing a move like
F4 and not worry about whether or not
it's the most accurate move in the
position it's still a big big Advantage
which is going to lead to a win and you
can see in kamy's face that he knows it
as well there's some nice variations
though to consider one thing we did not
talk about is to move King to F6 in
response to cck this looks like a really
bad move but we need to look at why it
loses Rook to F check would be possible
and now there's a simple but attractive
looking Checkmate you don't see every
day this move Queen to 86 would be mate
with all the black pieces Walling off
the king from being able to run anywhere
and if we go back a couple of
moves let me get this
here oh computer loves the fact that
it's mate doesn't want me to back up
look at that uh let me let me uh refresh
this board so I can do that actually at
the moment my position is frozen so I
will get back to some other lines in a
moment but it's clear that Carlson has
this big Advantage he's so cool he's so
calm I think he probably even prefers
not to play a move like Queen h8 a move
like F4 that just sits there and says I
got you son it's over don't move anymore
it's bad so it's looks like kamsky is's
going down in the very first round back
to you guys sometimes on those National
Geographics you see prey playing you
know uh Predators playing with their
prey and that's what that move F4 uh
kind of brings out to my mind that it's
a luxury of just you know I've got such
domination in the position and we do
have a few moves in this game uh let's
let's check out the blood que to A3
happen so just trying to maybe now for
C2 at least you have Queen A1 Shack
which would uh Force the uh The Rook
back to C1 mhm um also eyeing some pawns
as you point out and after Queen A3
Queen h8 was played okay so introducing
those uh those twin Checkmate threats
yet again right and then we we had Rook
to G7 okay um and queen H5 check Rook G6
and now we've reached move 40 okay so uh
the time control has been reached with
the time control being reached the
players get additional time uh added to
their clocks I um what was it was it 40
minutes or
um an additional 30 right so okay yeah
we also see we also see that uh Nakamura
and aonan have made time control also so
the players have made time control and
now uh um Magnus just figuring out the
easiest check mate and let's see this
again why is this different than that
previous line that we were looking at
Jen in this case after Rook f 8 when the
queen was still on the D6 Square you
pointed out the devastating move Rook C2
with the idea of Rook takes G2 in this
case with Queen A1 check um I can force
the white
king uh to capture the pawn and make it
hard youing H2 no and this makes it
harder uh so this one is not the winning
line that the easy winning line that it
was a moment ago so do we have a better
way of
continuing
here uh after Rook
G7 well he could let's see so wait but
but this is uh this was this so he
hasn't Magnus hasn't played Queen to h8
yet he's he's got the Rook still pinned
down yes exactly I was just uh trying to
set up a situation that we had moment
ago that looked very good for wide but I
can't recreate it uh with the queen on
A3 right yeah I mean that even that
position probably is somewhat promising
for for white but let's try to find
something better all right so we just
back up a move or two here so Magnus has
made the time control and now he's just
trying to find the most precise order of
moves that will bring him Victory and
and looks like we have a game over in
the other game a handshake Nakamura Aon
on oh my let's it it seems as though uh
you know nakur actually finished this
off in
style oops that was not the game I
apologize I bring up game two and we're
expecting to hear from these players uh
in in the uh just in in the next few
minutes so this will be a treat for all
of you listening in at home we thank you
for joining us absolutely so how did so
as you pointed out nakur had a lot of
ways to try to finish this off just uh
go G4 and double the Rooks um and let's
see how our top player decided to uh
reel this win in yes his choice was to
begin with the move King F2 Rook A6 G4
just driving that Knight away uh the
Knight on F5 is protecting Black's
kingside Knight H4 F4 oh I really like
this move now notice that with this move
F4 Four Leaves this Knight on H4 really
stranded this is beautiful play by
Hikaru Rook
C6 obviously attacking this Pawn on
C3
check and the devastating doubling of
the Rooks that we all know and love so
well Rook F6 to defend F7 simultaneously
attacking the pawn on F4 Hikaru had it
all worked out King G3 protects the pawn
attacks Black's Knight black was forced
to play the move G5 and then after F5
once again the Knight is completely
stranded on H4 it's not going
anywhere
H5 Rook F Rook E6 and this is where I
believe um game over uh just game over
we're taking L had seen enough we're
taking we're taking on F6 we're playing
Rook D6 check and then we're we're
grabbing that that guy on B5 and that's
the end of the game well I think what
he's going to actually do is just go
directly into stone cold win with a king
and pawn
ending yeah this is a this is this is
the fourth one with with with more uh
energetic play for black yeah nothing
nothing devastating so Applause very
many people are applauding forar nak you
know he did start off on the internet
you know he didn't come from the uh from
the great Armenian training SCH of
course we do have a lot of Great
American trainers but not exactly that
same
systematic um you know support that some
other stars around the world have had
right so Nakamura actually Rose to fame
becoming the best Blitz player in the
world and particularly on the internet
yes indeed one minute chest three minute
chest this was all his bread and butter
back in the day before he was a top 10
player so it's not surprising to see um
the internet Community uh just go nuts
when he wins his H first game in This
Magnificent stage now he's played in
tournaments like this all over the world
but this is the first time he's played a
tournament of this caliber in the US
exactly on home soil yes even more than
home soil his hometown now exactly right
this is where he where he uh he hangs
his hat when he's not traveling well if
you if there's ever a tournament you
want to win uh this one is it for hikaro
uh obviously uh the most elite event uh
Elite tournament event played in the
United States ever in the history and
we're expecting the um the players and I
believe in fact leavon has joined us and
yeah we're gonna we're going to get
leavon Aron on in just a in just a
couple a couple minutes as they get set
up for the interview let's take a quick
look and see if Carlson kamsky has
finished yet or if uh Carlson's still
looking for the right way to try
to I believe we yeah yaser is uh
switching the board right now and we've
got a queen HJ Rook G7 so they have
repeated this position another time
right and uh Carlson trying to figure
out this queen A3 move um a nice
defensive idea especially under time
pressure right if you didn't have that
Queen on A3 it would just be completely
cut well that was the whole point that
the move
F4 gave the queen on D6 the opportunity
to move to a 3 and make White's Victory
a little bit more problematic and um F4
was nice but maybe
excessively so just the direct Queen h8
would have probably won much patience
it's possible I don't know I just think
maybe he underestimated the the threat
Queen A3 the power of Queen H and we do
have Grandmaster Lavana Ronan in the
studio with Grandmaster Maurice Ashley
for postgame
interview thanks a lot Jen Grand Master
Leon aronia number two player in the
world but a difficult game today it
seemed as though you had worked your way
out of what seemed like a slightly
inferior position and then this move
Queen B5 uh must have come as a shocker
to you yeah of course it's embarrassing
uh I rarely make bunds like this and I'm
really
embarrassed well there's not much to add
that I think the game was interesting uh
but of course uh then move 28 I was
looking for an advantage actually here
but then yeah cuz there are some tricks
with Queen E3 or Knight E3 even It looks
interesting but then I decided all right
here is the for draw and my gosh that's
just crazy did you relax in this moment
when you realized that you had been
slightly worse maybe but everything had
just been easy now you had outplayed him
basically to to get a nice position do
you feel you relaxing too much here yeah
I thought I'm slightly better and then I
thought all right I'm I'm really not
then I'll just go for a draw and I mean
uh I you know that's one of the things
that they teach little kids if you see a
force line check if at one moment you're
not blundering anything and I've been
telling that to to my friends many times
and I'm falling into that myself of
course I'm I'm very
disappointed so game one you've got to
bounce back still five rounds how do you
do that well I did it all my life
actually I've lost many games and one
tournaments actually I don't really
remember a tournament which one the the
one that I won without actually losing
so but let this be my only loss but how
do you do it how like you lose in the
first round what is the mindset for
those who are not the world number two
what do you do to get your spirits back
so you can come back in a tournament
after you've lost well mostly I lose
because of something like this
so and something like this is just
concentration and I just start
concentrating better so more focus more
concentration as the tournament goes on
what do you think about this game
between kamsky and Carlson before you go
uh did you get a chance to look at this
game while it was going on uh yeah it
was it was an interesting game I thought
that kamsky took over at one moment but
now looks uh looks very dangerous for
him I think there has to be a win for
white I have a feeling well the computer
agrees with you and the rest of us do as
well maybe rook f8 and Rook C2 Queen A1
King G2 and then uh somehow I'll get to
your
king all right well we wish you the best
thanks so much for coming down and
talking with us we wish you the best in
the rest of the tournament thanks thank
you Grandmaster leavon aronian after a
tough start but as he said he loses
sometimes in and then bounces right back
so we look to see him do that in
tomorrow's games back to you Jen and yes
well I'm sure he doesn't get to be
number two in the world by uh getting uh
all bent out of shape by a loss so we're
going to see a lot of more exciting
chess from leavon and uh thanks to him
for coming down to talk about what what
is a very tough moment for any chess
player absolutely very gracious BL very
gracious and that's what it was I mean
just a stone called ah howler we say in
Seattle a move that so bad that you're
cries of Anguish can be heard in the
next County absolutely yes and uh we do
have our our Victor also going to be
joining us in a couple minutes um okay
our our local star hikaro Nakamura also
a star in the world stage and now
picking up some more rating points you
know he's always a fluctuating between
those like five six seven spots so a win
like this is always great because you
know he wakes up the next morning and he
sees himself in the live rating list
kind of creeping up right going up in uh
on the world world rankings rather than
Magnus Carlson who's kind of firmly in
the number one position right there's a
gap between himself and the aonian so
what uh uh aonian had said is that in
this position after he uh leavon was
following us Jen he liked your move Rook
C2 and he was saying that after this
move King takes G2 um after some
maneuvering uh black king is simply too
vulnerable which we agree read and we we
we knew that all along and that
eventually uh White should win but this
move F4 really spoiled magus's big
advantage and he's made it difficult on
himself now we have our Victor of the
first round not mauce Ashley is with
Grandmaster hiara
Nakamura indeed joining me is
Grandmaster Nakamura after a big first
round win in this the inaugural
singfield cup Hikaru welcome and congrat
congratulations thanks it's good to be
here now that first round game it looked
as though he played this crazy move C5
very aggressive very tricky and you
didn't go for it right away but then you
got what looked like a pretty decent
position out the opening yeah I mean
it's it's hard to tell I mean I actually
kind of was expecting this line from
leavon so it was nice to see it on the
board but then he then yeah he played
the C5 move which really uh surprised me
and then I mean all my moves looked very
obvious but somewhere in the middle game
I felt like I might have been slightly
better but
uh then then eventually I mean he just
defended very well and it was it was
just completely equal and at this point
it looked really equal he seemed to
relax in this moment just trading off
pieces were you stunned when the move
Queen B5 appeared on the board yeah well
I mean not right away I actually I mean
I was expecting him to go Queen C6 and
then I was I was actually ready to offer
a draw myself so I mean it's it's just a
careless blunder on its part and it's I
mean it's very unfortunate of course for
him but I'll certainly take it I imagine
but how did you feel at this moment when
you saw Queen B5 and you looked and
you're thinking what's going on um I
mean didn't really register I just kept
play kept playing r i mean I I tend to
be a bit more of an expressive player
and I'm pretty sure if you look the
video I just looked very uh very normal
so I don't know I was just just trying
to play the best moves even though I
mean because the thing is even though I
was up in exchange it's still not
completely simple there still are
potential drawing chances so I just Tred
to stay focused and find the best moves
well now you're plus one great way to
start a tournament uh how you feeling
about going forward in the rest of the
tournament second round um I mean I'm
just going to try and play good moves
really uh obviously it's nice to win the
first round but uh there's still five
more rounds I mean all the players are
very strong so I just have to keep
playing playing as well as I can and
hopefully it's good enough to win the
tournament Before I Let You Go this game
between kamsky and Carlson were you
keeping your eye on this game as
progressed not not a whole lot I mean I
I felt like uh I mean I I felt like I
mean Carlson was a little bit better the
whole way really um maybe at some point
I thought kamu was close to equal but
looked to me like he was a bit better
but now I'm no I'm not so sure I mean
what's what's happening but nevertheless
I mean it really doesn't matter what
everyone else does if I if I play well I
mean I really should only be focusing on
my own games because I can't control
what everyone else does so I'm just
going to try and focus on my games more
than uh than worrying about the other
games professional attitude well thanks
for joining us and congratulations on
your first win thank you look forward to
the next round grandm Hikaru more out
the gates 1 and0 great way to start back
to you Jen and Yas I just wanted to ask
um hikaro what he felt was the critical
moments in the game after he just left
the opening in the middle game we came
to that position where he played C3
Maurice if you could just ask Hikaru
what uh motivated him to play that move
C3 and show him that move Knight A5
moment that to me was a this was the key
moment of the game indeed thanks yes for
reminding me about that this position
here you play the move C3 uh and thanks
for staying with us a little bit this
the computer has suggested this move
Knight to A5 um and I it's hard for us
to go all the way back with the way this
setup is but Knight at A5 was a very
powerful looking move as an alternative
to what you did had you looked at this
move at all um a knight A5 yeah actually
I had I thought that black would simply
um I thought the black would just take
take on A5 Bishop takes D5 and then I
think I was just expecting something
like Queen B6 and I thought I might be
slightly better but I didn't I didn't
see a clear Advantage but of course in
retrospect it probably is a better try
than what I did in the game all right so
you did see the move all right indeed
well thanks again and we'll let you go
rest back to you guys
say thank you hikaro that that that
clarifies that that well I also wanted
to ask Nakamura we're not going to bring
him back but I also wondered if he felt
a little bit of sympathy for his
opponent after the blunder and he's
walking away no he didn't he's not
answering that one we've all been there
we've all made Moves Like 2% sympathy
98% Joy oh without I think it's even 3%
sympathy I really do I mean Super Guy
like leavon yeah I know I mean and and
you know you want to win because your
your your move spoke for themselves and
you were a deserved winner in this
particular case obviously he was gifted
the point we like to say but let's uh
return to the game that we do have on
hand gifted the Half Point rather was
full point gift is even bigger yeah so
let's see what has happened in this game
we return for a second and I think we're
up to date with the moves are
we or not we've got a it looks like
we've
got um yeah Rook G7 you've got Queen f8
check King G6 and King kicks
G2 uh yes exactly so check he so he did
didn't check with the Rook he checked he
checked with this queen I see and in
this position he played King takes G2
okay so what Magnus is figuring is that
he's just going to park his King where
it's nice and secure here on F3 and then
he's hoping that he'll be able to harass
uh Black's King with Rook G1 and if that
all goes according to his plan indeed
that looks like a winning script that's
right so if for instance black would
take on B3 here are just King to F3
right and that would be curtains for
sure because thanks to this check
followed when the King has to drop back
either to H7 H6 or H5 then you've got
this queen and playing itself to h8 and
as Maurice was saying with the queens
and the Rooks the major piece of
circling Black's King uh Black's king is
not going to survive long so let's see
if we can't improve God his defenses for
a moment instead of capturing that pawn
let's see if we can't do something let's
let me
try uh I don't believe in myself in this
moment Rook G7 H7 so that I could check
you if you went King
F3 now what do you see as the winning
move we could start with Rook G1 that
looks like the Chang the move order as
we as we always try to tell our students
in chess if you find kind of win and it
doesn't work because of some defensive
resource switch the move order see if
that makes it work right and I must say
that sure does look like it works to me
Jen uh we're getting the final piece
into the game that's so critical here
right because you got the queen and the
Rook working but we need to get that uh
that other major involved The Rook on C8
the queen on f8 are definitely doing
great a great job and that Rook on C1
now on this G file ready to give a
discover check as soon as the king steps
out of the way of The Rook that's
curtains I don't even I don't see any
defense uh let's go back we're at this
moment and of course we can't even move
our Rook on E7 because our Queen on A3
is in take let's just let's just make
some check we we don't really have many
checks we can we can only throw in one
check really right on B2 check on B2 and
maybe Queen H and play Queen H2 here
that makes a lot of sense bravo bravo I
don't think it's going work but it's at
least try it's a Bravo because you're
protecting now the G1 Square in fact
that's such a good defense Jen I'm
thinking that I shouldn't even allow
your queen to cross over to the king
site so I'll block your check hopefully
I'm provoking you into capturing the
pawn so that in case you do capture the
pawn then I go King F3 and now you're
the black king is at the mercy of
White's Rook again Rook G2 and Rook H1
so instead you were thinking what queen
A3 or something to continue some
pressure I don't think it really helps
that much though no I think Queen B2 is
a what we say in the business Spike
check one check before we leave uh
before we leave the game perhaps Maurice
you've seen the defense it looks awful I
can't find it what about you sure I see
defense call resign the game is over
this is bust all the way uh kamsky is
sitting there he's staring at the board
it's one of those situations you know
when you're just busted and what can you
I mean look at his face it's clear that
he knows it's over just staring at
losing variation after losing variation
can make you so depressed as you're
looking at the chess board so no
question about it he's going to just
have to deal with the fact that he's
lost the first game and that's it and in
the meantime what I think is interesting
twofold one is that aonian made this
blunder that lost him the game but
Carlson made not the most accurate move
as well Queen h8 was a crispy kill and
instead he's got to do this little
finesse stuff under pressure he found F4
instead of Queen to h8 so it's clear
even when you're the numbers one and two
in the world that doesn't mean you play
Perfect chess that doesn't mean there's
no chance to escape or you know maybe
make some small errors in Carlson's case
he's still going to win the game so he's
cool and about the situation knowing he
has his opponent all dead to All rights
and the second thing I noticed is aonian
attitude this guy is so Frank he's so
direct he's so open a lot of people
might not have said how embarrassed they
were you know this childish blunder that
I made but he just sitting with him and
having dinner and talking with him in
the football game you realize he's just
an open cool guy ready to speak his
heart and you know he he wants to fight
definitely and he's ready to to go and
play the next five rounds so I've really
become a much bigger fan of heronian
since meeting him on this trip he really
seems like a first class guy and a chess
player absolutely it's hard to find
somebody who doesn't meet aonan and have
a positive reaction I mean he came into
the chess club just after landing and
started playing the first people he saw
playing Blitz well so certainly not a
snob at all just like a a a really great
guy U maybe he because cuz he's number
two in the world he has a lot of modesty
if he ever becomes number one he'll turn
into a hug
sure not really obviously number two in
the world is uh it's I mean I know a lot
of people who are uh you know the best
player in their clubs and uh have a
massive ego as a result so World Champ
really nice to see that world champion
itis so it's a virus that afflicts those
who become world champions that they get
too big for their own Bridges now we got
a gotsky just uh total frustration here
it looks like he's going down in this
game despite you know some some efforts
to really uh keep it keep it exciting
and uh take it to Magnus Carlon uh
everything backfired and his King is in
in the gutter here with all the major
pieces flying at him only there was just
one less major piece you might be able
to kind of Wiggle around with his King
but all three of them coming at the
artillery is just too heavy um we should
point out tomorrow's pairings um aonian
is going to be playing against Carlson
with white so say that again I'm got
white against Carlon lovely number
Nakamura csky Nakamura with the white
pieces so two whes in a row for Nakamura
because uh of his color allocation that
they will play each other twice yes once
with black once with white but still
kind of a nice way to start the
tournament with two whites and got by
contrast starting the tournament with
two blacks it's a very difficult thing
to do when you're playing in such a a
tough tournament absolutely a lot of
people you know instinctively think
maybe it' be better to start with the
black so you can get it over with but
I'm not so sure about that I think like
if you actually look at the data you'll
see that starting out with the
confidence in the momentum is probably a
little bit better
agreed so let's see what Maurice has to
share
Maurice well I think when I look at
these kind of tournaments it's always
pretty depressing for the person who
loses early right because you lose a
game and then you have to play another
monster Imagine a I has just lost a
bitter game to Nakamura and who does he
get not like in a Swiss system you get
somebody else who lost a little
tailender you get Carlson so you're just
in trouble again and maybe Carlson is
going to try to hunt you down realizing
that maybe you're not so focused or
concentrated or what's even worse or
maybe not worse but what's good for
Carson is maybe aonian spirit's not so
up and he might just want to make a draw
so either case when you're in these
super tournaments the these guys smell
blood in kamy's case he will have lost
this game he's going to be bitter after
losing and then he's going to have to
face a Nakamura who you know doesn't
offer any draws and he's going to be
hunting him down as well so very
difficult for the two in losers in the
beginning of a tournament and I think
this is going to favor Nakamura in fact
because Carlson is probably going to
have a tougher time against aonian with
the black pieces than Nakamura will with
with kamsky since he will have white so
the early bet is for Nakamura to start
maybe taking a little bit of a lead if
we start to project a little bit in this
Tournament of course it's still a long
way to go and Nakamura has a horrible
record against Carlson and he has two
games he has to play against him so we
could put the breaks on and not project
too much but looking at it it seems that
Nakamura has to feel like hey I got a
gift in this tournament maybe it's my
lucky day maybe it's my lucky tournament
back to you guys thank you Marius yeah
every day in this tournament it brings
just a thrilling contest um so we we
hope that you'll join us every day abut
fact we do except the Thursday we do
have a rest day then
yay to recover from all the excitement
and to give the players that extra boost
of energy at the halfway point we do
have some moves uh um God has been been
in a desperate position for the last
half hour or last 10 moves or so after
this move King takes G7 King takes G2 as
uh Maurice was explaining white needed
to play a little bit more subtle than
Jen what you showed was a very crisp
line um we didn't find anything better
than what G has chosen he played Rook on
G7 to F7
attacking White's Queen and hoping to
take advantage uh of White's Queen if
White's Queen for example had come back
to h8 this is a variation that g was
looking for uh that finally he could get
his Rooks and maybe okay no he's still
probably losing even in this case cuz
there's a king F3 is going to be so
secure here in any case G is looking to
try to give Magnus as many problems as
he could and uh after the move Rook G7
F7 Magnus played very simple move um it
was Queen d8 right yes Queen to d8
onward and uh got responded with Rook to
H7 right Rook
H7 and in this position we we're
expecting this simple Play Just The Rook
on C1 shifting over to the G file so
that when the king moves to
F3 that king move would come with a
discover check to goddess King and that
looks like it was going to lead to
Checkmate yeah just a
total
lack lack of defense for uh for God and
you just saw the look on his face he
just uh really looked very sad there
well I can understand very very well his
truly heightened sense of
frustration because as the Grandmasters
who came down and were interviewed by
Maurice were saying well they all
thought that g had taken over at a
certain point and he had an advantage
there's no no you know losing in a game
of chess is what happens I mean it goes
with the sport you you know you take
risks to win but you
really get angry with yourself when you
lose a game where you held an advantage
well this is tough also because it's not
100% clear like he really put his heart
into this game it's not like with leavon
where you can you can just point out
well that was an egregious error yeah
this is really the opposite in which he
actually seemed to play pretty
impressively and then just somehow the
the thread was lost and Magnus came up
with these great resources uh with his
Bishop to E1 and all of a sudden the
bishop becoming a monster and just
holding back what looked earlier to be a
mounting attack right well we all admire
and with with understanding players like
great Michael Tall who sacrificed their
pieces this was simply a stunning
defensive gem uh really great
effort the move F3 was quite a surprise
Queen D1 then this move Queen E1 this
Shifty little move on the back rank that
had all kinds of subtleties that led to
uh a dark Square bind uh Magnus
defended there I use the word genius say
magnificently magnificently and like no
no we've gotten three hours without
using that word we're doing so well
weren't we uh but really this was a
great a great uh demonstration that
sometimes in chess defense wins just
like in sports from time to time so you
were truly impressed and it is great to
be able to watch these games slowly
because there's only two games and we're
really able to just like dissect
magnus's every move and you know see how
he wins yes cuz he's not like the the
Kasparov who comes in and blows you off
the board in the opening right and
defeats you tactically with stunning
sacrifices Magnus can do that but what
we also see is that he likes the
Strategic the slow uh uh grinding wins I
mean he didn't come out of this opening
with any great shakes it wasn't like he
had an advantage of any type in fact I
felt he stood slightly worse at a
certain moment and
then he simply outplayed his opponent G1
was played Magnus has played the move
Rook to G1 with the uh just basically
the same idea of King F3 but the correct
move order not allowing that move Rook
to H3 ah so just to point that out to
our audience so it's the move order what
you were say to your students like like
what always look for alternate move
orders yeah so you want to play the move
King F3 but you also want to say the
reason why King F3 immediately isn't
good is because you you get checked by
Black's Rook uh this is harassment and
you don't want to allow black that
opportunity and that's why you play the
move Rook G1 which was played and now
there is no Rook check and further
the king is threatening to move with
check on its own and this looks
like the money move and it's always fun
to win a game by moving your king and
releasing a Jack that's quite unusual
right right you set you set up your
opponent with a discover check by moving
your king you're right that does have uh
gives you a greater sense of Aesthetics
it's a a beautiful way of winning a game
and for go it this is really a torture
because what he's doing right now un
fortunately is he's chiding himself for
you know like letting it his Advantage
slip and rather than really thinking
about resigning or something like that
he's playing back in his mind as we all
do what did I do wrong why where did I
let it go wrong where did I lose it and
so this is what he's he's fighting
against himself with yeah tremendous
fighter cam he really is he really is
none of these guys like to lose but I
think of all of them G is one of those
people who really digs in his heels
almost in a superhuman kind of uh way
what he did in his game match against
Shaq midaro in trumo recently in Norway
oh to to walk out of that game unscathed
and draw as black nothing but Applause
Just Simply a great example of his
fighting Spirit oh right and and
recovering from the fact that he missed
a a maiden three I mean that that was
like that was he missed a maiden three
in one game with black where he had that
Knight G3 and oh yes yes and I mean
again as uh Leon said he was embarrassed
right but and he still won the match and
he still won the match and that that CHS
a lot of character and he just has he
has a great character and he shows it
again and
again so let's see what he's facing so
if God it we're just going to put a move
on the board for a moment just to just
to show our audience where where uh what
what could happen in case we see this
move Rook E7 to G7 this is not a
particularly good move after King F3
discover
check if Black's King were to step back
well then after Rook C7 check it's going
to be mate in a move or two black would
be forced to interpose his Queen and
then it would be
Checkmate uh shortly and after King a
H uh six we would have a Checkmate in
this
direction immediately immediate
Checkmate and in case of come on in case
of King H5 I believe it's this move
there's probably other checkmates but
this one looked pretty straightforward
to me Rook takes Queen
takes
and we have some moves on the board we
have moves on the board what has he done
and uh I think uh Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley has the update for
us well actually I was just pointing out
a Checkmate earlier in that same line
that you were doing y with Queen to H4
check but let's definitely then switch
back and get to this position I think
that it's interesting to note something
here for those of you who are just
starting out or not so familiar with
chess ideas you look at this PA
formation it looks very much much like
both kings are exposed the pawn
structure is exactly the same and
everyone has the same pieces why is it
that White's the one who's winning this
position well the simple difference is
in peace activity and peace activity
trumps everything in chess trumps po
information it trumps even central
control if you have great active pieces
attacking that's the whole difference
and the the problem for black is that
his pieces are not coordinated they're
off in la la land everywhere they're not
together Rooks just defending the king
queen over here on A2 and instead
White's the one who's penetrated and has
all this going for him so the despite
the fact that everything is almost
symmetrical in the pawn formation in the
middle these pawns look exactly like
twins and the Kings look equally exposed
but in fact they're not just because of
the activity of these pieces and we can
see this black king is being circled and
will be checkmated by these white forces
or some massive win of material so big
Advantage definitely for Carlson and the
game has concluded they have had the
handshake let's see the last few moves
guys because it was clearly in Carlson's
favor the whole time that's right and we
do have the the finale of the game two
decisive games to start off the
singfield cop is a fabulous beginning to
what we hope will be a fabulous and
historic tournament here in St Louis um
so what were the final moves let's take
a look right well the for an elite event
to start with two victories like this
this is pretty uh remarkable so we saw
rookie one there came this move Queen A2
check to the white king king F3 respond
to a check with a check you don't get to
see that every day check check so check
check happened and then after check
check uh King F6 I believe was played
and then King
F6 and I think it was Queen G8 yes Queen
to
G8 all sorts of mates so with the with
the move Queen G8 we're ready to bring
our Rook we're ready
uh you pick your mate exactly that's
exactly right so instead we we throw in
what you call a couple little little
checks here a spike check so Rook H3
check appeared in the board and now
after Rook takes G3 Queen takes
G3 the threat of Queen G5 check or Rook
F Rook
f8 that is devastating enough that would
uh complete the game and and it was at
this moment that g gave it a rest that's
right so two victories out of two games
my goodness and at the highest most
elite levels uh we're used to seeing
roughly speaking 75% draw perhaps even a
greater number of draws and here we are
starting out with 100% remarkable that
being said that game between Nakamura
and aronian was supposed to be a draw
and we're getting a lot of um comments
on our our Twitter feed here uh with
respect for ronan's sportsmanship and
attitude yes um to keep a smile like
that well understandably disappointed
great human I like that not just great
Sportsman great human human yes I like
that and uh yeah we just uh have another
uh Ashley speaking highly of ronan's
attitude after the game a class acting a
true
gentleman and yeah some some some High
Praise here of course you know keep your
comments and questions coming today and
s cop we are going to get the players
down momentarily so let's take a look
and see what we've got inore tomorrow we
wait wait for them to come down we've
got aonian with the white pieces against
Magnus Carlon two top players in the
world right going to be a mega battle
exactly um aronian of course extremely
disappointed dare I say embarrassed but
he's going to get over at by tomorrow
the embarrassment will be over right and
Nakamura playing at csky with the white
p
exactly so well in a few minutes uh we
will interview our first player um
overall I must say uh one of the things
that happened to me yest well not to me
but what I observed yesterday yesterday
uh the players all did a signing there
was a book signing and there was a line
that went from the book signing room all
the way down the block and this line was
just full of children who had brought
their book boards and their software in
their chest sets and they were all
wide-eyed in excitement and you know
that is something I've just never ever
seen in in the United States before that
was just very powerful uh did you pick
up on that yourself did you see the line
uh J oh yes I did see the line and it is
great to see this is the chess club and
Classic Center in St Louis we' got
programs hundreds of programs all over
the city trying to you know bring chess
to to kids especially kids in the Inner
City it's risks it's great to see that
um and uh hopefully they're they're
rooting on their favorite player here
exactly and one of those players is with
us um our our current reigning us chess
champion God hamsky just crowned here in
St Louis a couple months ago is with
Grandmaster Ashley Thanks Jen I am with
four-time US champion gakamsky after a
difficult game G it seemed as though at
some point you would equalize did you
feel good about your position somewhere
in the middle game yeah I started
playing for a win somewhere but it was
not uh based on reality I guess you felt
like you were attempting to win but
somewhere at what point did the win well
seemed like it was was not right to do
well when Magnus he played Rook C2 and
back Rook C to C1 I realized that
basically he was just um either trying
to win time or I just didn't want to
take risk and then I wanted to you know
expand on the king side but if I hold my
knight on6 and Pawn on H5 I don't think
white can do really anything much he'll
have to take a risk and Play3 E4 and try
to break in the center and then it will
be really double-edged so instead I
decided to go attack and um then I just
didn't see anything were you surprised
by how tepidly he played the opening it
seemed like he just didn't try for
anything at all coming out the
gates well you know he is famous for
squeezing out the small advantages so I
didn't want to give um him that
opportunity you know to get a small
advantage and then slowly you know like
green me out but um so I tried to attack
you know like when in doubt always
attack and it's always easier to uh
attack than defend but then at some
point I don't know uh when he played F3
I realized that white is just better so
after that was um really difficult game
for black so you know it's an
interesting game so how do you respond
to opening round loss like this
one okay it was an interesting game and
um I think it was pretty interesting
because um it showed that although I had
Queen and Knight and some space
Advantage um white controlled the only
open line with his Rooks and um he
struck uh he struck back at the precise
time with F3 and Bishop H4 and uh just
teaches you that you have to be patient
and wait for your chance and um that's
what it is about tomorrow you you face
uh one of your main Rivals here in the
United States SAR Nakamura what do you
think about how you prepare for
tomorrow's game no
idea we'll just go and play some chess I
guess all right well thank you so much
for joining us got after a tough loss we
wish you the best in the future games
all right thanks Grand Master gakamsky
with us and back to you Jen than you Mar
and uh a couple little stats as we wait
for world number one Magnus Carlson one
of the victors today got two two
decisive games right America versus the
world 1-1 okay right one win for the
world one win for the United States
we'll we'll will'll split the first
round yeah and the youngsters both won
as well oh no I hate that that's
terrible yeah my veteran got
ating for him a long tournament though
and all these guys obviously relatively
young so um but we do have our our world
number one Magnus Carlson getting set up
right now for his interview with uh R
Master Maurice Ashley I'm sure you're
all excited to see that his first major
tournament in the United States this is
really a thrill for everyone in St Louis
and for everyone watching all the chess
fans of the world you bet a lot of
people are asking about you know his
match against aad and whether you know
he's thinking about that in this
tournament and his his openings are
affected by it so it's going to be no I
think his focus is definitely on this
event what happens in the future happens
in the future but right now it's today
it's the present yeah that's how you get
to be the best and here they are
Grandmas morrice Ashley with world
number one Magnus
Carlson Thanks Jen with the highest
rated player in history Magnus Carlson
after winning his first game against US
champion gakamsky first of all welcome
and congratulations thank you now here's
what I want to know is the real secret
that I taught you football yesterday at
the Rams game why you had the energy to
win today yeah uh I don't think so I I
thought um
I thought after yesterday that I might
actually be able to teach you a thing
about thing or two about Chess today
after you talk me something about
football but um the game was a little
bit too messy to be to be
um to be U worth
um
whatever well uh you definitely had a
good time yesterday I could see that you
were pounding on the railing and
enjoying yourself but today you were a
lot more subdued your opening seemed
like not that much uh were you
intentionally doing that maybe not to
show some stuff to the guy in India what
you're preparing for him or did you
decide just not to play so aggressively
against kamsky who's been a tough
opponent for you I thought my my
opponent now I mean my opening was fine
thought it was slightly better I I had a
good Bishop against his Knights his dark
squares were a little bit weak but then
I drift Ed uh but perhaps that was um in
in a way what I needed to do because I
lost a lot of Tempe uh and gave him an
attack but in the end uh he
overestimated his attack and it
rebounded rebounded on him I got a
Counterattack on the same flank indeed
you played Rook to C2 and then Rook back
to C1 and that's we were wondering what
was going on these deep ideas but then
suddenly you play some great defensive
moves like Queen D1 and F3 were you
proud of that move F3 when you played it
yeah I think it's a good example of um
defending economically that you don't
want to use more pieces than you want to
in defense and you want your pieces to
both attack and and defend like my Rook
on C2 both attacks on the C file and
defends very well on the G on the G file
and perhaps he uh underestimated my
defensive resources there and uh he
didn't re real didn't probably realize
that the attack was going to be more
dangerous for him than for me now in one
moment you had a choice and maybe you
were in time pressure you played the
move F4 but it like Queen h8 was really
powerful for you had you considered that
move or just time pressure you decided
to play F4 instead and just keep
everything cool uh yes I I was
considering Queen h8 but I thought Rook
D7 and there was nothing um clear but I
thought after F4 he would practically
have to resign because I'm threatening
Rook G8 King King takes Queen takes and
then Rook C8 and it will be made
immediately but I I missed Queen A3 but
fortunately I I I had a little more time
I found the the the Right Moves and made
it him anyway indeed a great way to
start off a tournament with a win but
tomorrow you get aonian number two
player in the world you guys are good
friends but uh on the board he's your
main Challenger how do you feel about
tomorrow's game going in I thought I was
playing uh Nakamura tomorrow well we'll
have to check that we don't want to mess
up the guy's preparation Jen you will
let us know in a moment but I believe I
believe you are playing aonian tomorrow
so let's let's scrap that question until
we can confirm uh what happens there
after a win like
this what do you do do you erase it from
your mind completely or do you let the
positive emotions drive you forward what
is a a Champion's mindset after a big
win in the first game uh well I I have
some some mixed emot
I was very happy that I was able to win
uh there was some good elements in in my
play that I think I calculated pretty
well uh played very well in in the
critical moments but before that my my
play was a little bit Rusty so I'm very
happy to have gotten a win now I'll
unwind and it's always so nice to to to
start with the win and to be to be there
immediately so um we'll we'll see
tomorrow but I'm very optimistic you
this is the first time American fans
have gotten a chance to listen to you
here on us soil and you're playing in
this prestigious event what are your
thoughts about this super tournament
finally happening here in the United
States I'm very I'm very happy to be
here uh the playing conditions were very
nice and and quiet uh today and uh
especially the pieces were uh were good
they were a little bit unusual from from
what uh what well from what I'm used to
um especially made chessboard right they
made it just for this event but they
were very very elegant very nice so so
that was a joy indeed so we want to see
you here many more times did we get a
data on that as yet Jen Jen conf that
she's
righton is his he is playing against
aonian tomorrow so maybe you hurry up
and check that so now your thoughts on
playing against the world number two
player especially after his loss did you
see did you pay attention to his game at
all today the way he lost a very bad
blunder yeah I I saw that he suddenly
lost an exchange I didn't understand
what happened if it had been forc
sequence or he just uh it was just a
blunder clear blunder yeah
then um yeah he's probably going to be
pretty upset about that he he was his
words were that he was embarrassed and
that he played like a child yeah uh that
sounds about right
uh well we'll we'll see um I'll try to
to pound on on that of course um to
continue my momentum try
and kick him while he's
down
um um but he'll probably be like a
wounded tiger tomorrow very very
dangerous indeed well thank you so much
for joining us congratulations on your
first win uh in your first tournament
here in the United States Magnus Carlson
the world number one player starting out
with bang in the first tournament here
at the singfield cup the first round
here at the singfield cup back to you
guys jenz thank you and we love that
honesty I know it's so so refreshing um
what a way to end the show kick a good
man while he's down that's what the
world's number one player has in mind
tomorrow and I'm looking forward to
another spectacular round great
stuff and yeah just to address uh the
confusion actually Magnus Carlson is
playing leavon Aon on tomorrow probably
his fantastic score against Nakamura he
can't wait to play him like when do I
get when do I have my appointment with
Nakamura he's looking at his watch but
they they they all they'll all play one
another twice yes and he's going to wait
till Wednesday for that but of course
tomorrow we've got our two thrilling
contests aonan playing against Carlson
with the white pieces feeling sick about
the game yesterday but he does have
white and that will be thrilling and
then we've got Nakamura and kamsky the
two top players in America so you are
going to have to join us we're going to
be here again at 1:00 Central and that's
at 2 p.m Eastern and before we sign off
we've got one more final thought from
our commentator Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley well I think we've seen
everything today two great victories a
crazy blunder uh and also attitude
you've got to love it I mean these guys
are straight out of Brooklyn or at least
could have been kicking Wild is down
that's what I'm going to remember from
today great honesty in the players and
leavon ronan's attitude when he lost as
well you see that chess players are so
professional one thing that I noted when
I had dinner a couple of nights ago with
the players was just how very the
conversation was we spent about three
hours talking about all kinds of things
Finance uh uh racist attitudes around
the world uh The Great Australian
Barrier Reef the Great Barrier Reef in
Australia all kinds of stuff tons of to
ICS not one word of chess the whole
night and just showed that they are such
well read people well cultured and just
great guys to be around so great
tournament for us to have and a great
start of course to The singfield Cup oh
absolutely and one tidbit is they
they're all fans of Al somehow oh yes we
all know Al so we can't wait to see you
tomorrow watch the world number one try
to kick a man who's also number two
while he's down and we will be back with
more tomorrow tomorrow 1:00 here in St
Louis 2 p.m Eastern I'm Jennifer shahadi
signing off for Grandmaster yaser Saran
Grandmaster Mor Ashley and the whole
team here at the St Louis chess
[Music]
club